yeah welcome to this video a 15 minute
game and I'm playing it international
master Richard Jones from Wales I played
him before just about two weeks ago and
I lost this game from for a pretty good
position maybe I overestimated my
chances a bit but it was certainly very
good for me
okay I'm playing the CARICOM um this is
shiny
mostly because I just did a video series
for ICC in German language which I
advertised a bit already on the channel
and there I'm presenting a repertoire
for black against all moves but I'm
starting with one e4 and I'm starting
with the CARICOM actually I'm
recommending exactly this variation that
Bronstein Braunstein poor shrine laws
and variation of the kurakin with G
takes f6 which is a very interesting
line it is some not very popular amongst
top grandmasters I mean it's basically
never played but it's not not so bad
actually if you look at Black's recent
results um you can see that black is
scoring quite well it's um it's um what
does this move
I mean I can just take this pawn and I'm
not quite sure what what's the big idea
yeah okay for me at least this is just a
blunder I think I can just take this
don't understand it yeah of course he
went see temple but temple isn't isn't
decisive here blacks position is fairly
solid in the center and he cannot sound
due to this pawn mass yeah especially
the pawn on f6 and he cannot go Knight
e5 or anything so it's not so easy to
get any direct direct play here
I was playing 25 in order to have Bishop
f5 available also I can go Bishop g4 not
sure what you what really and what the
idea of Bishop b3 was yeah the most
critical move on startup we should be
three is probably c3 all right so my
queen a5 just loses for the tempo with
Bishop d2 I think we should are going to
Queen here it's probably probably
logical yeah now I'm wondering um if I
play rook g8 how does cm how does he
react to that I'm just threatening this
pawn and I would I would really tell
would take it if I'm given the given the
chance I can also just play Bishop to f5
with no particular problems but okay I
like to attack this phone
don't don't know how how we would defend
it really rook g1 is really a
stupid-looking move play Bishop g4 and
immediately threatened on f3
gee three years is also very strange
yeah but if I'm what I'm not not getting
as if I take now on g2 and threatening
Bishop to g4 winning this piece okay he
can go Bishop default but then I play f5
talk about a weird game I don't get it
absolutely not maybe long castles Bishop
g4 Bishop c4 f5 and then count that
Queen d2 threatening made on d8
something like this
if I go Bishop before and he plays this
Bishop b4 reply I can also just play em
just play 97 mmm not sure at all maybe
maybe it's not such a great idea Bishop
c4 Bishop c4
you should be for I'm not I'm not sure
Queen d2 as a possibility and and maybe
h3 I don't want to get into herself in
with taking on nonage 3 I could I could
play Bishop f5 but then he would take
and play em light to edge for problem
it's not not so great what if I am
Knight to d7 and could do that
yeah Bob Bishop g4 certainly the very
principle goals but f4 even h3 looks
like a possibility there's always this
mate idea on the aid if you play
specially for Queen d2 maybe I should
play a simple move like a night to a 612
for instance I'm wondering let's say
Knight a six and he plays I move like
Queen d2 threatening this on on the 8th
but I can I can just play a bishop movie
our Bishop g4 I have five maybe night a
six keeping this possibility open and
preparing this this bishop moves on to
cover the eight also maybe that's at one
time night c5 on my before
yeah maybe this wasn't so bad not quite
sure what white would do now I mean he's
always a bit tied to this to this knight
on f3 cannot really um yeah he went for
this I thought um Bishop to g4 was good
now maybe then maybe then an IT one
could be but first let's let make sure
that really I cannot take on on f3 it
just plays Bishop to e4 Bishop to e2 and
I cannot cannot cover d8 so probably am
I need to move from the bishop on c8 the
question is where if I go to reform
we had a thought so made on d7 of course
if the bishop is sir the bishop is
moving away from this diagonal
you
yeah it's quite tricky
let's say Bishop g4 I mean I probably
threatening up the eight to to pin him
yeah one Bishop g4 in place like there
should be four probably I cannot play at
five
maybe I can play then night to see five
Wow this is getting tricky maybe this
was too greedy in the syrup the2 gets
possible okay let's start with this mess
I'm hoping that I'm not 20 50 91 I can
just take h2 and I didn't think about
that move
I had this was stupid
oh man
yeah talk about gifting away a full
point
I mean after Bishop d3 black just wins
or move six okay but rook g8 and maybe
this was was a bit too too much okay
but let's see where we are still have
some some sort of defense I mean it
doesn't really look good but yeah I
cannot take f3 because of May 27 the
should everybody why didn't I think
about this what what yeah it's not
exactly a difficult move I mean
so there anyway to to proceed here get
at least some chances I don't see
anything
I mean I mean of course that it would be
some sort of need some some some tricks
or something but I don't I don't see
anything yeah d7 I cannot really cover
this square in any any meaningful way I
can't go FIF and put some piece on
before yeah come on maybe maybe this I
don't know very stupid very stupid play
yeah I really need to play this guy
again zero points out of - what - two
games that that are just that has been
just winning I mean this is just bad I'm
also pretty sure if I don't plunder tuba
should have won I mean this is never
enough compensating cannot believe
that's really he just blundered the
default phone and then first was lucky
to get to get some kind of compensation
because I maybe was too greedy yeah I
came in - what whatever doesn't help
yeah Queenie to e4 you can just move the
sir this Bishop and I'm threatening
nothing basically
you
why didn't he go Queenie - yeah no one
knows okay let's let's take this least
I'm getting getting a bit of material
back it still lost probably but he could
just play Queen e2 and I resign I mean
okay the problem is I still cannot
Castle and he's got probably Queen d3
coming
yeah whatever it's still it's still bad
I mean he could just play Queen e2 and
be a broke up but probably am queen d3
is still winning now I was intending
Queen to G fallen before probably to e6
I've got a pawn for the exchange but
still pretty strange pieces on a6 and
before group is also not playing
the edges Queen d3 would be in but be
good I think
simple simple moved to cover c4
threatened on d7 and coordinate pieces
but maybe there's something something
else
Rock d7 mm-hmm maybe you can try to
finish black off instantly with rope d7
King takes Queen f7 Bishop e7 group d12
BM could be good it's not necessary of
course but maybe this is yeah maybe this
is why I was thinking okay at least
check don't need to invest any time and
checking for alternatives I just need to
take if I go back now
hmm yeah doesn't really it doesn't
really help but so let's say I go to see
age or to see playing then look t1
probably well King d8 um
rook g1 with check it's nonsense King do
6 also someone and Bishop e7 group t1 is
probably also curtains yeah okay man
let's go here the rest loses 100% so
this probably also but
I don't I don't see it yet look here
okay
your g8 cannot cover I can I can go here
play Bishop g8 it's probably just lost I
mean
26 26 wins
Queenie 6 mm King c7 rupee g7 is over
King d8 v8 anything also
Jack yeah it took his sweet time to find
the smooth but it's nothing nothing I
can do really yeah it's just made I mean
I could I can resign them okay let's uh
let's let's play it out
Rupert she's shiny and and queen yet for
meet Jack okay so black reason my next
move
yeah just just a terrible game I mean I
mean by of course also by him may mean
he's lost after mu six and so but it
doesn't help if you play a rubbish like
we should reform then you just lose the
game
yeah simply dreadful
branding blundering to to Bishop f1 the
compute action the computer actually
gives gives me a defense after this with
Bishop rook F - isn't it amazing
sometimes what's possible in chess after
Queen takes bishop takes I'm talking and
and actually win with the ton of pawns
up and after Bishop takes I have Bishop
h6 it's a pin there should be three
takes takes takes and after she won I'm
still playing I mean it's unbelievable
check what a crazy line and black is
still fighting maybe I'm I'm bad in the
long run but it's it's a game okay so
okay still it was completely unnecessary
to do this
yeah okay yeah Bishop e6 is given by the
computer with the key advantage but I
don't know probably rook g8 maybe this
was just really too greedy I mean all
night a6 I don't know here the computer
gives 97 with the winning position of
course 95 maybe coming on 95 yeah it was
it's clear this is complete nonsense
what White was doing and this should be
three especially it's just just terrible
I just take it and I'm winning it's an
extra pawn for nothing but it's
questionable maybe root gh g2 was to be
too bit too much but okay it's winning
what can you do but of course you
shouldn't play at least overlook stuff
like this I mean and after this of
course and I'm just lost I could have
easily also resigned but yeah I was all
ours all the time thinking about we
should eat too or we should before but
somehow should f1 I I didn't really take
into account
yeah those undeveloped new sometimes
difficult but yeah just very stupid play
and oh well in the game I mean this was
unnecessary you can just play Queen e2
but this is of course a winning group
she won now wins instantly and okay this
is also I mean this is so lost that you
can play all kinds of [ __ ] and this um
this is made already a force made yeah
alright not the best game by me but ok I
need to play more 15 minute games to
finally beat this guy from a winning
position instead of losing yeah thanks
for watching I'll be back soon